[Musique]
eh bien oui nous avons tenu le pari
on avait décidé que les reporters les
journalistes de stade 2 et est misogyne
je ne suis pas où et quand ne voulait
pas entendre parler du football féminin
est bien christine paris se charge de
nous parler de football féminin même si
j'allais avoir du tout peur je vous pose
la bonne question êtes vous pour ou
contre
je me pour non match il faudra pas vous
étonner de voir un reportage de très
féministe nous allons voir les rémois ce
qui sont championnes de france depuis
huit ans et je cède la parole à jacques
chazot qui trouvent cela évidemment très
disgracieux tellement grotesque que j'ai
déjà du mal à suivre le vrai foot alors
avec les femmes
vraiment c'est pas ça qui m'a rangera
avec elle voit des gens je suis pas
tellement pour parce que je trouve pas
ça tellement sport pour une femme enfin
qu'est ce que voulait puisque ces
demoiselles va les jouer on va les
empêcher les hommes sont pour la plupart
contre le football féminin
ils trouvent cela inesthétiques les
femmes ont aussi le droit de préférer
alain delon ou paul newman ces sportifs
là le football féminin est né à reims il
ya dix ans il existe en france sept
mille deux cents licenciés répartis dans
trois cent cinquante clubs et joueurs
ceux reconnus par la fédération football
et ils ont un statut amateur mais un
groupe extra sportifs financent leurs
stages et leurs déplacements ainsi les
rémois sont elles allaient jouer aux
ânes aux usa et même en urss
[Musique]
à l'époque moi j'en ai fait parce que
c'était original parce que j'aimais le
sport et puis parce que il est de créer
une équipe de foot alors que c'était
qu'elle une idée toute nouvelle en
france si on peut dire ça fait quelque
chose d'assez particulier toutes les
filles à l'époque en mal d'originalité
et surtout de sports de plein air parce
que c'est quand même le seul sport de
plein air auxquelles les femmes
n'avaient pas accès c'était intéressant
[Musique]
jésus la capitaine des rémoises a débuté
comme gardien de but elle joue
maintenant avant centre et se défend de
pratiquer un sport viril
non je pense pas vous voyez je vais
marier j'ai une vie familiale très très
heureuse et je n'ai pas de problème et
je suis très fier je pense pas que ça
peut devenir viril à l'effet on est
femme n'y a pas de règle avec d'être
brutal aux joues un peu on peut jouer
plus dans ces sit in est ce ça peut être
d'autant plus agréable de jouer à un
football plus simple et économique
c'est bien plus aujourd'hui que de jouer
très brutes ça ne porte rien pourquoi
vous l'avez posée je me demande encore
peut-être le fait que commence ce soit
une fille comme sportive plutôt qu'une
fille
enfin plus féminine si on ne peuvent pas
plus féminine mais plus du mannequin
plus favorisés j'aurais pas émis avant
tout une femme comme ce mariage tu sors
et isabelle tue pas se poser le pied
gauche michel tu passes avant semble et
elle reste ça bouge pas alors il ya deux
trois trucs mamie quand tu fais de très
belles montées mais tu sais plus quoi
faire
sylvie tellier à abandonner
définitivement l'athlétisme pour le
football après moins d'un jour elle joue
habituellement à paris avec l'équipe des
lilas je viens surtout de découvrir une
chose que je n'ai pas connu en 15 ans
d'athlétisme esprit d équipe qui pour
moi est très important parce que à
l'athlétisme on est seul on est toujours
selon pendant mes dix années j'ai été
seul quand je battais un record j'étais
sûr que ça faisait plaisir qu'à une
seule personne à moi et l'entraîneur
aussi alors que là c'est tout à fait
différent je sais que si j'ai le bonheur
de marquer un but moi je suis moins sûr
que la ronce personnes qui sont
contentes en même temps que moi
pierre geoffroy le football féminin
n'est-il pas le refuge de jose androgyne
oui mais ça ne pose pas de problème
enfin pour plus à plusieurs conditions
vraiment il faut pas que c'est ses
joueuses en question constitue
l'ossature la majorité des effectifs
dans les clubs il faut qu'il y ait un
équilibre
or les filles qui veulent rester femmes
sont conscientes de leurs de ce problème
et font vraiment le maximum
il faut que sur un deuxième point
l'entraîneur et les dirigeants qui
encadre les footballeuses les aides
justement à ne pas tomber dans une sorte
de caricature du footballeur sommes en
adaptant le football à la femme n'aura
de toute façon pour débutants les
mijaurées ou des lesbiennes cet arrêt
sévères problèmes sensation complaisance
est-ce que vous avez conscience du fait
que les spectateurs viennent vous voir
un peu un bête de cirque
je pense pas très honnêtement je pense
pas sinon j'aurais arrêté tout de suite
parce que la féministe que je suis
n'aurait plus supporté longtemps regarde
les spectateurs venus en voyeur disant
je pense que maintenant et surtout c'est
encore plus probant maintenant que les
filles y gagner leurs galons en matière
de football
je pense qu'on vient les voir jouer pour
voir du bon bois
[Musique]